[Music]
he was impossible to ignore Silvio
Berlusconi was a giant figure in Italian
life for decades on end in politics
business Sport and on the global stage
his fortune was built on broadcasting he
constructed a media Empire and made a
vast Fortune
he spent some of that on molding AC
Milan into Europe's best football team
and then turned his attention to
politics from the center right he led
four separate governments spending more
time as prime minister than any other
post-war Italian politician we find
but it was never straightforward
Berlusconi was cited in dozens of
criminal investigations mostly around
claims of fraud he said that was
persecution and claimed to have been in
court two and a half thousand times
trouble did follow him remember this
woman a Moroccan dancer nicknamed Ruby
heart stealer
Berlusconi was convicted of paying her
for sex when she was just 17 years old
at one of his lavish bunga bunga parties
they were taking part in a burlesque
competition and they trained for it
because these women by their very nature
are exhibitionists they are show girls
who like to put on a show and compete
but he won an appeal and laughed off the
Scandal bunga bunga became a catchphrase
not a source of Shame
then came a conviction for tax fraud
that he couldn't beat Berlusconi was at
his lowest air and protested furiously
on one of his own TV stations
in exchange for the commitments I have
made over almost 20 years in favor of my
country and coming almost at the end of
my public life I received as a reward
accusations and a verdict that is
founded on absolutely amazing it takes
away my personal freedom and my
political rights
he was a global figure he hosted three
G8 meetings that is a record
but his brand of diplomacy was eccentric
he famously left Angela Merkel hanging
around while he took a phone call
eventually she walked off
he once welcomed a Spanish prime
minister warned me to Italy only to
cheerfully stroll away from their joint
scheduled press conference leaving Jose
zapatero utterly bemused
but Berlusconi was blessed with an
infectious smile Rolling Stone magazine
once named him their rock star of the
year he had Charisma and he knew how to
get in touch with people and even if
sometimes he could
[Music]
look like a little bit strange eccentric
but at the end he was a very friendly
pet
remarkably he returned to politics once
more part of the Coalition that pushed
Giorgio Maloney into power still a
political heavyweight into his late 80s
Silvio Berlusconi was a man who lived
for the spotlight